the Russian doping scandal starts all
the way back in November of last year
the world governing body of athletics
provisionally suspended from track and
field competitions after the world
anti-doping agency or wada finds
evidence of state-sponsored cheating the
full complement of 389 athletes is
technically still headed to Rio but the
track and field team are in doubt skip
forward to June this year and 67 are out
as the International Olympic Committee
or IOC upholds the Bern the IOC has set
the bar a lot higher for Russian
athletes in terms of doping so any
Russian athlete with a prior suspension
for doping can't compete in the Olympics
Russian athletes are allowed to compete
at Rio but if they've been suspended for
doping in the past they're out a month
later and wider publishes the mclaren
report recommending a blanket ban could
this mean no Russian athletes at Rio the
independent wada report made it pretty
clear that there was a state-sponsored
cover-up in russia it wasn't just to
cover up the sports ministry ran as
doping the program and the cover-up less
than a week later and the IOC decides
not to ban the entire Russian team
guided by a fundamental rule of the
Olympic Charter to protect clean
athletes instead and much to the anger
of wider they let the sports as
individual Federation's decide Russia's
got a lot of political weight in the
Olympics there one of the big three
Olympic medal winners and I think the
International Russia is unlikely to
contest' the IOC s decision because they
were facing a much stricter ban and this
way at least some of them they'll be
able to hear their a national anthem a
few times by the 25th of July and the
number is down to 288 as 22 rose five
canoeists and seven swimmers band
by the end of the week 16 more athletes
a band with the final number going to
Rio at just 271 the Russian squad is
barely 70% of its original strength I
think Russia is very happy with the
result that they got they were facing a
blanket ban in which all of their
athletes would not be allowed to compete
with a few exceptions clearly there's
gonna be a lot of soul-searching Russia
is gonna lose medals that we thought
they won in Sochi I've seen estimates
that up to 30% of all Olympic athletes
are doping so obviously a lot more work
needs to be done it's unclear maybe
there are other countries that also have
state-sponsored doping Russia could just
be the tip of the iceberg